le 78 weekend ce sont aussi des idées de
sorti pour les deux jours à venir et
pour commencer j'accueille Olivier
Besson bonjour bonjour metteur en scène
mais également professeur au
Conservatoire d'art dramatique de
plaisir je vous reçois parce que ce soir
vendredi et samedi la ville de Plaisir
accueille votre adaptation du roman
cloche merle écrit par Gabriel chevalier
au parc du château c'est une pièce qui
est satirique une espèce de fable des
années 20 qui se moque de son époque
est-ce que vous pouvez me raconter le le
pitch en une minute alors et ben le
c'est c'est d'abord un roman très très
célèbre alors peut-être que les
nouvelles générations l'ont moins dans
la tête mais c'est même rentré dans le
dans le langage commun pour dire que
voilà qu'il y a des histoires très
compliquées dans pas seulement dans un
village d'ailleurs souvent on dit oui on
dit c'est cloch mer voilà donc c'est
donc moi j'ai essayé de faire une
adaptation pour le théâtre à partir de
de ce roman et en
grosoire histoire en quelques mots c'est
l'histoire d'un maire qui a un grand
projet pour sa mandature et son grand
projet c'est d'installer une pissotière
dans le village gros projet en effet
c'est le gros projet d'investissement de
des 6 années c'est ça et là ça divise
tout le village c'est ça et le truc
c'est que il va le placer à un endroit
stratégique dans le village qui va
réussir évidemment malgré lui à mettre
il va réussir quasiment à se mettre à
dos tout le monde et notamment l'église
puisque le la potire est quasiment
contre l'Église et très vite tout le
monde tout le village va être obligé de
prendre parti pour contre la pissotière
et donc on va avoir d'un côté les
urinophobes et d'autres les urinophiles
c'est comme ça qu'on dit c'est comme ça
qu'ils sont appelés dans le voilà c'est
comme ça que Gabriel chevalier s'amuse à
les à les appeler et à partir de de de
cette anecdote il va montrer comment
cette anecdote se est monté en épingle
comment la chose va dégénérer comment
peu à peu ça va dépasser les anjeux
locaux ça va devenir une affaire
nationale voire internation nationale je
raconte pas comment ça finit mais voilà
mais ça va très très loin quand même et
et voilà et donc c'est sur le ton de
l'humour du 2e degré et ben c'est très
voilà c'est c'est les c'est dans
l'esprit des chansons de brassins c'est
dans l'esprit des des romans comme ça de
des années 40 50 c'est roman très très
satirique comme ça où on se féroce plus
féroce que satirique d'ailleurs où on se
moque à la fois de toutes les
institutions donc des curés éidemment on
va se moquer des politiques on va se
moquer des Mar jalou des maris cocu
c'est en ça que c'est assez actuel en
fin de compte cette c'est assez rigolo
mais oui je crois que les notamment les
les politiques qui viennent VO le
spectacle rigolent et se disent tiens ça
me rappelle quelque chose ça parle de
nous voilà ça se passe dans les années
20 dans un village donc imaginaire mais
en réalité évidemment ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir comment
effectivement une histoire de rien du
tout peut tout d'un coup déraper et puis
très vite plus personne ne contrôle rien
voilà ouais alors c'est aussi quelque
chose de presque trivial ça parle de
cocu d'urine c'est très populaireou ah
bah oui oui oui c'est c'est ça cet
univers très populaire ben voilà vous
avez typiquement dans les chansons de
brassins hein o voilà on va parler de
curé de de curé qui couchent avec leur
bonne et cetera mais aussi d'histoire
politique et ce qui m'intéresse c'est
qu'il a une manière de regarder les
choses par le petit bout de par le petit
bout de la lorniette qui qui est joyeuse
mais qui en même temps d'une férocité et
d'une
méchanceté
VO sur le comportement humain sur son
époque et qui clairement voilà les
choses ont pas tant changé que ça
lorsque vous commencez à grat un peu et
vous regardez pourquoi tel ou tel se
positionne comme ça politiquement
socialement et cetera et ben souvent
vous avez derrière des petites histoires
de rien du tout des des anecdotes qui
font que on va se positionner voilà des
querelles de des querelles de clocher
des querelles de cloch mer exactement
alors tout ça ça se passe en plein air
donc ça a des avantages des
inconvénients déjà j'imagine c'est
extrêmement diff différent que de jouer
dans une salle classique de théâtre
qu'est-ce que ça change pour vous à la
mise en scène et ben j'aurais je ferai
jamais ce projet là en salle à priori ah
oui parce que bah le pleinir a de
grosses exigences c'est très compliqué
il faut aller vite h il faut pas être
trop bavard il faut faire en sorte qu'on
soit audible parce que très vite vous
avez un avion qui passe et on entend
plus et cetera le public et appé
immédiatement par des tas de choses qui
se passent à l'extérieur vous êtes pas
dans le noir concentré face à un plateau
h HM voilà toutes ces contraintes làont
qu'il faut vraiment aller chercher le
spectateur en permanence pas le lâcher
le tenir avancer dans le récit
l'intéresser tout le temps sinon ça
marche pas h contrainte du temps de la
météo également on sait pas siil va
faire ce so voilà contrainte de la météo
on a joué deux fois pour l'instant 14 15
juin vous voyez le temps qu'il fait en
ce moment on n pas eu une goutte d'eau
ce soir puisqu'on joue il pleuvra pas et
demain soir évidemment et demain soir je
sais que le ciel
joue pas vous ne jouez pas c'est voilà
mais on se prépare tout le monde
s'habille les acteurs s'habill on est
prêt à jouer et puis si vraiment le ciel
est pas avec nous et nous veut pas ce
soir là bah tant pis c'est un spectacle
qui est gratuit vous vous basez beaucoup
sur l'interactivité avec le public hein
c'est ça il y a beaucoup d'échanges il y
a même des jets de salade dans le public
si j'ai bien compris oui oui oui bon
voilà il y a une petite bataille de
salade non seulement dans le public mais
avec le public puisque voilà on est dans
un dispositif un peu particulier
effectivement moi ça m'amuse justement
on n pas de salle donc on n pas de
contrainte d'espace donc notre espace on
peut l'inventer complètement donc on a
inventé un espace pour raconter cette
histoire avec cette envie c'est ce que
je souhaitais qu'on ben qu'on soit tous
sur la place du village d' certaine
manière public et acteur donc je fais en
sorte que ça se passe partout au milieu
du public derrière eux devant eux et
cetera à côté d'eux et puis des fois
avec eux et notamment évidemment dans la
mesure où on va avoir cette guerre qui
va arriver très vite entre urinophil
urinophobes et ben on va essayer de
monter la moitié du public une moitié du
public contre l'autre on va les appeler
les invités à s'injurier à s'insulter
gentiment on reste voilà ça reste de la
comédie du jeu évidemment et puis à un
moment donné on va leur donner des armes
pour pouvoir un peu attaquer le camp
adverse vous leur donnez des armes ah la
salade et en l'occurrence les armes
c'est des salades on est quand même dans
un pays rural donc voilà donc on trouvé
que les armes les moins contendantes et
les plus rigolotes à avoir volé c'était
possiblement c'était les salades et ça
donne quoi alors parce que vous avez av
déjà joué les 14 et 15 juin dernier ça
donne quoi sur le public ou on s'amuse
beaucoup ouis crois il est réceptif ça
marche vraiment le jeu de salade là ah
oui oui oui oui on a même du mal à
l'arrêter même à un moment il y a un
petit bal et on va faire danser un peu
le le public et cetera voilà donc on
joue ensemble je crois vraiment que ça
c'est une chose que j'ai beaucoup
pratiqué par le passé à partir du moment
où on emmène le spectateur dans une
histoire où il accepte tout est là où il
accepte de partir avec nous dans
l'histoire alors il est capable d'aller
très très loin et de faire des choses
qui vont l'étonner lui-même c'est c'est
évident voilà donc donc on on s'amuse
ensemble beaucoup et puis j'imagine que
le cadre joue aussi hein vous êtes dans
le parc de du château de plaisir c'est
ça ah ben on a un cadre absolument
formidable ouais voilà donc d'un côté on
puisque on joue à 360° donc il se passe
des choses partout autour d'un côté on
va voir le château en arrière-fond et
puis de l'autre côté on va voir la
prairie et donc évidemment notamment
pour les scènes qui se passent chez la
baronne euh et ben le château est
prédestiné et puis voilà donc cet espace
ouvert comme ça et a une ouverture sur
l'imaginaire et ce qui fait le décor
c'est évidemment l'espace euh qui est à
notre disposition et c'est les costumes
et on a des costumes ces qui sont
impressionnants voilà bon et ben tout ça
est à voir donc dès ce soir et demain
soir à 20h30 au parc du château de
plaisir et c'est gratuit et c'est
gratuit merci beaucoup d'être venu pour
nous en parler merci à vous